there's two people in the back those are
safe and if you see two safeties up top
it's either going to be covered two
which is zone or is man with two deep
savings but if you look at the people on
the corner of the screen that's called a
cornerback you see that because the way
he's positioned over there this is
covered too there's two savings up top
but you see the corner is on top of your
wide receiver over there those the wide
receivers are the people that catch the
ball so this is man the man hold on see
the safety came down so now it's one
safety on top you see that
so chances are it's a blitzing version
of cover three two seconds but you see
the corners so what's that what defense
is that man that's right that's made up
that's what I'm talking about girl two
safeties what we thinking
so when the two safety split that
outside was running the post number